does a screenwriter have to live in los
angeles preferably no but
but um it helps you know tremendously to
live in los angeles to be around the
business
there's no doubt about it uh like we
were talking about
earlier you could be out anywhere and
run into somebody
you know not that your choice of
networking but
you're around it there's so many any
night there's a screening
there's um academy screenings there's
writer's guild special things where you
can meet the filmmaker
and american cinema tech has them all
the time the filmmaker's there
you can ask questions you know to learn
and study
and you don't get that in
smaller places or places that aren't
hollywood you know
and now you can work it but let's say
you get a meeting you're going to have
to fly in and that meeting could end up
being
just a general meeting that yeah you'd
drive to pasadena for
you know 28 miles but you're going to
fly across the country
and it could end up you know you want to
maybe schedule a few of them
but you know what i mean it's sort of
it's it's not um it's not impossible
so no one should say well i don't live
in hollywood i won't be a screenwriter a
lot of people live outside of hollywood
but you're gonna have to throw your
stuff into the ring
and uh come out for meetings and have
that expense be able to get off from
work
these type of things and and
traditionally
um i don't know what town size that
somebody might be in
but you're not running in those circles
or somebody says hey
come to this party or i got the
screening you know to meet people
you know to put it out there uh or or
the
festivals that that are here all the
time you know you can enter you can
enter your film obviously
from elsewhere but to go to them and
network you know and stuff like that so
it's not impossible but there's so much
here if you work it you know what i mean
if you
yeah what about not knowing the
temperament is the wrong word sort of
having a pulse on the end of such a
cliche or
having a pulse on the industry but
really there is a different
way of working in la and just because
somebody says great we'll be in touch
it doesn't mean that where it might mean
that more in the midwest where people oh
sure
might be more apt to keep their word and
or i'll read your screenplay
okay right so so six months later
and and knowing that actually two years
later they could actually call you so
you don't want to get mad and shoot an
email
so yeah how dare you know so there is
like this different
protocol here and and if you don't live
here and you're around different
surroundings
where things may mean what they mean
right then you hold them to a higher
standard which they
don't they go what did you mean you
believe to me well i believe a person of
their word you expect me to be that way
well
forget it jake it's hollywood you know
well sometimes they keep their word it's
just several
years later yes it just takes longer of
course yeah and and so
the natural inclination would be to be
hurt or angry and
but really if you just kept that door
open
it could actually happen yes you want to
burn any bridge ever right right
but maybe people don't understand that
there is like a different way
yeah they'll learn quickly if they if
they come out
here you know and and and you know go
wow this is i
have to change my you know the way i
deal with people well
i wouldn't change myself i would still
be that person who you are i don't you
know drop to that but
it would be frustrating when no one else
like you're saying is
is plays that way they play with their
own rules
sure or you could be so
you wouldn't hear from someone for a
very long time and then the next thing
you know
now you're always hearing from them yeah
feast or famine sure yeah yeah that
happens
so so from just visiting here i don't
think you would get that
no you wouldn't just to come out for a
meeting you'd be whined and dined and
or maybe not maybe it's just a general
meeting you know me sometimes
a meeting is just a meeting get a soda
yeah cigar is just a cigar
people online oh i got a meeting you
know blah blah and they boast about
okay that's great but what happens
when i've been to a million general
meetings myself and they just want to
meet you and say glad to meet you and
that's great
but it doesn't mean you know i used to
love to have oh my god i got a meeting
you know because the potentiality of the
whole thing you know then you learn
some people's job is just to take a
meeting they want to have a face with a
name and
that's it and maybe if you've got a
product and you can show them a script
that's something great
but it doesn't mean they're going to buy
it tomorrow but you build on that you
know you build build build over a number
of years
you know um so then being
i'm sorry so then being here
it's not just the cost of going to a
meeting and getting off work and being
you know
it's also knowing how things work and
what
a word being uh
in a way in front of them more than out
somewhere where you know what i mean you
could potentially
i don't see you know if if i disappear
you're off my radar i mean you could
there's still email yes but i'm saying
that face to face
like and then what about the last minute
meeting that came up
you're not going to be able to get a
plane flight red eye to fly out you know
what i mean so
if things bob and switch you can
tomorrow go oh my god i can i can go to
warner brothers
it just opened up or you know what i
mean so
you know but don't leave your family and
your job
and say i'm all in you know because it's
going to be rough
you know unless there's a guarantee like
they're flying you out
you know type of thing you know it's a
done deal they're buying the script
you know but i just think living here
puts you
around it all the time if that's on your
if that's what you want to do
you know what about
jinxing something by saying guess what i
got this
meeting or guess what of course all the
time that's why i tell them
i have a blog article about you know
keep your
like in poker you know have your don't
spread it out there because
many times it's gonna bomb and then what
do you you know it's going to look like
yeah you know you're boasting about this
meeting it could be it and
you're let down um in front of everybody
else you know your
your failures which is fine but you
don't want to present that too much
you know it's a private thing you just
say yeah i'm working on it you know i
got some meetings and it looks good you
know
because a lot of energy is spent and i
understand the anticipation the
excitement of it you know you want to
share that
but it's also a big fall you know
they're gonna make the movie
well not until the check clears you know
i've been many many times and the head
of production goes oh we'll be shooting
in you know six weeks and
it's seven weeks what's going on you
know if i told everybody
you know oh i'm going to quit my job i'm
going to do that you know
be a high big fall you know so it's a
lot easier
to blow just to be sort of even keel not
these
too hard to over the long haul to have
these big ups and downs it's just the
middle
the middle areas the best place to be
you